number two 30 second rounds interesting
first you mean recognizer and bring up a
loop to party she's not inviting
ourselves policy 30 seconds on the clock
this fight starts now right TIF God has
a tattoo on her thigh that says SJW
which stands for social justice warrior
and not what I thought shitty joke
writer we can learn a lot from so
politically like you can look in our
eyes and
laughing right we both have come
together to be to close in available
[Music]
service very gender-fluid she identifies
both as a man and a woman sometimes like
when she's a drag she's very convincing
as a man when she's on stage she's not
like a woman
[Laughter]
haha alright so I don't know maybe don't
want he lives in his car
they've got a web series called
comedians living cars who can afford
coffee you may have seen him at the
Creek in the cave using the bathroom as
a shower of just kidding he doesn't
shower
I just using the bathroom for dumping
his piss jars down the drain and that's
based a fungus blush like eww Stan smart
my club is the winner of round one on
scare look very deep voice that applause
maybe your tall guys is the winner 30
seconds on the clock round 2 starts now
so I live in my school bus but is it as
bad and somehow he's picked up more
children than me
ok there was a point in time when we
thought we were perfect for each other
but then he started talking about the
children and Hans is a self-proclaimed
himself which I might really terrified
of roasting
I think after this I might have to like
a volcano or we might live in this car
that these Asians that one in five pawns
camp
I might good so but I didn't have sexual
relations with took em right here which
it shows you how bad the standards it
was a lot of time spent by to do array
Wow she took has a very big tits of a
porn star and the face of a porn star is
dog being friends with benefits which
means you'll be the only person that
doesn't have to [ __ ]
[Music]
hi my love is the winner of round 2 joke
hello Tori's the winner of round 2 on
skin
[Applause]